after the original Star Wars trilogy
concluded the saga continued with two TV
movies released over the course of two
years that while often overlooked now
remain fascinating installments in the
overall franchise decades after they
originally aired it's time to talk about
the Ewok adventures in 1983 Star Wars
seemingly ended its story with Return of
the Jedi the third film in the original
trilogy which saw the defeat of Darth
Vader and the Emperor and the triumph of
the Rebel Alliance though George Lucas's
prequel films wouldn't actually come
along for more than a decade he still
wanted to continue telling Star Wars
stories in some form this started with a
walks the fairy creatures from Return of
the Jedi and what was initially going to
be an Ewok holiday special for TV as
discussions about the Ewok story went on
the story expanded to feature-length and
the name was changed from a holiday
theme to the Ewok adventure in order to
avoid associations with the infamous
Star Wars Holiday Special from 1978
eventually known as caravan of courage
an Ewok adventure the first film was
shot in the California redwood forest
near Skywalker Ranch and premiered on
ABC in November of 1984 at the time the
first a walk adventure was conceived the
creatures were only known for their
appearance in Return of the Jedi and
Lucas and company wanted to keep the
story standalone as a result the first
film contains very few of the hallmarks
we associate with Star Wars
the Ewoks themselves and their forest
moon home on Endor are just as we
remember them aside from that there's
not much to make the film look like Star
Wars the character maesta Hwanhee wears
an orange flight suit and carries a
blaster and there's one star cruiser but
that's about it this sense of separation
from the main star wars saga begs the
question of when exactly the film's are
set and there was initially a little bit
of disagreement on that front in an
interview with Empire star Eric Walker
revealed that the original plan was to
set the film's decades after Return of
the Jedi completely separate from the
main saga later though Lucasfilm placed
the two Ewok adventures on the timeline
between the events of the Empire Strikes
Back and Return of the Jedi which means
the Ewok wicket and his friends were
dealing with humans well before Princess
Leia showed up caravan of courage the
first II walk adventure is the story of
sindelle and mace to Ani
the young siblings find themselves
stranded on Endor as their family
starship crashes
and their parents are abducted by a
giant monster called the Gore axe we
know the creatures name as well as the
names of the Ewoks because the entire
affair is narrated by none other than
legendary singer and actor burl ives
ives cool calm voice gives many of the
Ewok only sequences the feel of a nature
documentary deej who use his skin
lightener the search for the missing
times though mace is initially hostile
toward the Ewoks in part because he
can't understand them sindelle and
wicket become friends the Ewoks
then win mesas trust by finding medicine
for sindelle when she gets sick it's
here that magic first enters the pitcher
as the Ewoks take sindelle and wicket to
the mystical a walk low gray who shows
them their parents in captivity at the
fortress of the gore acts mace and
sindelle beg that you walks for help and
a select few are chosen to travel to the
gore axes mountainous layer to stage a
rescue with the help of some magical
artifacts the fantasy feel only deepens
as caravan of courage heads into its
third act
our heroes discover everything from a
wayfinding Arrowhead hidden in a rock to
giant spiders patrolling a massive web
inside the gore axes cave when they
eventually do reach the lair of the
borax mace finds his parents in a giant
wooden cage and with the help of the
Ewoks manages to free them while fleeing
the gore acts the Ewok touka trope dies
when rocks fall on him together with the
humans that he walks managed to kill the
gore acts by causing it to fall into a
pit and mace uses chucat ropes ax to
take revenge for his fallen friend
though there are hints of Star Wars here
the whole thing plays out much more like
a fantasy adventure if you'd never seen
a Star Wars film before this one you
might not think the franchise has much
to do with stars at all caravan of
courage proved to be a massive success
garnering 65 million viewers and two
Emmy nominations and setting the stage
for a sequel at the request of his
daughter who was saddened by touka
tropes death Lucas left out any Ewok
fatalities in the second film but
everything else was wide open
together the creative team hashed out
and even bigger fantasy saga that
introduced a number of new threats and
characters into Ewok lore the result was
a walks the battle for Endor which aired
on ABC almost a year to the day after
the first film in November 1985 the
battle for Endor opens just as the
t'lani family are preparing to depart
Endor in their newly repaired starship
but things soon get ugly of
group of marauders led by the evil tarik
and his shape-shifting witch sidekick
Charles storms the ship murdering the
entire family save for sindelle wicked
who's learned to speak broken english at
this point decides to keep sindelle safe
no matter what while wandering in the
forest sindelle and wicket meet a super
fast rabbit like creature named teak
teak shows them to the hut of noah a
hermit who crash-landed on Endor years
earlier and had no choice but to stay
when he couldn't repair his own ship
noah is angry at first to see strangers
even though one of them is a helpless
child but he agrees to look after
sindelle and wicket when they insist
they have no place to go meanwhile at
the castle of the Marauders Charl tries
to unlock the power of the fuel cell
from the t'lani family spaceship because
tarik is convinced that it's magic and
wants to exploit it for himself when
Charles
tarek orders her to find sindelle
believing she will know how to unlock it
Charl uses her magic ring which allows
her to change shape to turn into a
beautiful woman and lure sindelle into a
trap she takes the girl back to tarik
who demands sindelle give him the power
when sindelle reveals she doesn't know
how to do anything with the fuel cell
he throws sindelle and jail along with
Charl taking her ring meanwhile Noah
wicket and TKE begin to plan a rescue
mission they infiltrate the Marauders
castle and free sindelle enraged tarik
frees Charl and bird form and launches a
full-scale attack on the Ewok village
the creatures defend themselves much as
they do in Return of the Jedi using
things like rolling logs as traps as the
Marauders keep coming Noah powers up his
ship but tarik recapture sindelle no it
demands a duel with tarik with sin dolls
life on the line and as they fight
wicket uses his sling to hit the magic
ring around Tareq's neck with the ring
destroyed tarik turns to ash and Charl
is left in bird form forever with no
ring to change her back with the
Marauders defeated sindelle says goodbye
to wicket and leaves Endor on board
Noah's starship as we've already
discussed the Ewok adventure films are
only loosely connected to the rest of
the Star Wars universe the decision to
set them between Star Wars Episode five
and six however creates a number of
interesting implications that the film's
never take the time to explore the most
obvious of these is that by the time of
the Battle of Endor wicket speaks
English frequently with sindelle
Thunder now in the film itself this is
simply to cut out the need for a
narrator the second time around if you
think about it in a larger context
though it makes you wonder why he never
broke that skill out when he met
Princess Leia a short while later even
more broadly why are the Ewoks so
friendly with sindelle and mace but so
hostile to Luke Han and Chewbacca when
they meet them are they just spooked by
weapons did the run-in with the
Marauders make them nervous when they
first appear in Return of the Jedi the
Ewoks are depicted as a relatively
simple tree dwelling people who have
clearly defined a somewhat primitive
culture for themselves when it comes to
their supernatural beliefs or religion
we know that they seemed to worship
c-3po as a god upon seeing him I do
believe they think I am some sort of God
that suggests some kind of belief in a
deity but that's all the film really
takes the time to give us the Ewok
movies presented a really interesting
opportunity to expand on the creatures
supernatural beliefs caravan of courage
in particular decided to take advantage
of that opportunity and revealed new
layers of the Ewok culture through the
use of magic the Ewok shaman low grey in
particular seemed to have a real command
of the magical arts and before the
caravan set out on its quest he offered
that Ewoks and their friends a series of
sacred tokens tied to Ewok warrior
legends these tokens include a magic
crystal with hypnotic powers a magic
candle that seems to summon light fairy
creatures a walking stick that can pass
through magical barriers and a rock
which hides a magical Arrowhead the film
never has time to expand on where these
artifacts came from or how they work but
they all suggest a much deeper Ewok
culture lurking beneath the surface of
the film's the star wars heroes of the
original trilogy spent a lot of time on
Endor in Return of the Jedi and over the
course of that film we get the
impression that it would be a relatively
peaceful planet if not for the Empire
the Ewoks clearly have weapons and know
how to fight but most of their weapons
look more like what you use for hunting
than a war outside of all that Imperial
interference they seem to have a pretty
quiet and happy life in the trees with
the Empire out of the picture for the
Ewok movies Lucasfilm had to come up
with other threats for the characters to
fight and that's when it became clear
that Endor is actually a pretty
terrifying place to live even setting
aside the main antagonist of each film
like the gore acts and the Marauders
there are a lot of terrifying deadly
creatures to contend with on the forest
moon in caravan of courage alone the
Ewoks and their human friends must
contend with a massive beast called a
boar wolf the tree-dwelling trapper
known as tempt or and most memorably
gigantic spiders that dwell in a massive
web inside the gore axes mountain
fortress
no wonder the Ewoks are so good with
spears and slings we've covered the plot
setting and interconnected mythology of
the Ewok adventure films and now we
arrive at the question of their present
relevance are the Ewok adventures
considered canonical the short answer is
No which explains why we haven't seen a
blu-ray release yet the longer answer is
that for a long time the films were
considered a canonical part of the
expanded universe along with countless
other stories that formed a mammoth Star
Wars timeline that all changed in 2014
when after Disney purchased the company
and launched new plans for the franchise
Lucasfilm revealed that the expanded
universe as we knew it would draw to a
close this announcement meant that all
stories previously produced other than
the six core Star Wars films and the
Clone Wars animated series were rendered
non canonical
however the roll back also created an
opportunity for old EU characters to be
reintroduced later that means that while
the Ewok adventure films aren't canon
anymore there's always a chance someone
could decide to throw something like the
gore acts into a new tail check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]